en effet le labyrinthe jeu je fais klein
sont les tirs à la carabine mais aussi
tir à l'arc cheval mécanique et lancer
de fer à cheval
pendant les vacances les petits cow boys
et indiens ont de quoi faire à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet puis
le chef indien dont je m'occupe du camp
des indiens de cuir les châtaignes et de
surveiller un petit peu que les cowboys
viennent pas attaquer notre petit pays
d'aller voir il a eu vent qu'il manque
un cheval qui a déjà été embarqués par
les indiens donc nous on va devoir
défendre à deux dirigeants tout en
dépendant aussi la première à coup on va
le préparer dans les deux pigeons retour
à vouloir la protéger
on va faire un papier par l'hébergeur un
tir à la corde pour désigner les
vainqueurs puis on enterre la hache de
guerre sur des airs de musique country
cette animation se poursuit jusqu'au
mercredi 7 novembre
en quittant le far west les enfants
peuvent aussi visiter la ferme
pédagogique et se promener dans le parc